just thinking about the depths of the
ocean a place where almost no human
being has ever been the place we know
very little about we know more about the
surface of Mars than we do about the
ocean floor then I think there are
people potentially trapped I say
potentially because it's possible a
thing imploded on the way down they're
all dead now but the idea there are
potentially human beings living and
trapped down there it means a viscerally
terrifying it plays on every major human
fear simultaneously and it's also it's
also fascinating and it's also been
depressing at the same time to see the
reaction from the public to all this at
least on social media where people have
just been like outwardly contemptuous
scornful openly hating these guys who
are on the submarine